one thing that jumped out to me is you
both love diners Jersey diners so I I
lived in Philly for a while and I've you
know I traveled quite a bit and
traveling from Boston down to Philly
maybe to DC you can drive through Jersey
there something about Jersey I don't
know what it is it's the best you listen
to Bruce Springsteen there's a uh Lucy K
has this bit where I think it's part of
criticizing cell phones today where
people are too much on their phone that
don't just sit there be bored but he's
uses that story to tell where he's just
driving and the Bruce Springsteen song
comes on and he just wants to pull over
to the side of the road and just like
weep for no unexplainable reason um and
I think that's true because life is
difficult life is full of suffering or
struggle or Challenge and so there some
sometimes it's always always Bruce
Springsteen but like some kind of song
like this can really make you reflect on
life that melancholy feeling but that
Melancholy feeling is the other side of
the happiness coin where if you just
allow yourself to feel that
pain you can also feel the highest Joys
that's the sort of the point Lucy K
makes and there's something about jersey
with the diners often late at night now
there's several Diner experiences I
should say okay there's like the
familyfriendly there's a nice waitress
and this a sweetness a kindness like
hello sweetheart that kind of thing
there's also like the 3: a.m. Diner
where you're like the ones that are open
24 hours mhm that has a romantic element
when you're a young man or young woman
you like traveling the loneliness of
that all of it the American Diner is
like from like Jack caroak on represents
something I'm not sure what that is but
it's like a real beautiful experience
and the food itself too always fresh
yeah the thing with Diner there's so
much to love about it and I grew up
obviously in New Jersey and I'd go uh
you know with my father to to business
he'd always stop we'd eat at a diner
late night I'd be coming back with my
friends we'd stop at a diner and it's a
tradition that ianka and I love doing as
well and uh I think there's there's a
notion of it's very egalitarian and that
you know people from all places are
there uh you could order basically
whatever you want I mean the the menus
at the diners look like the phone book
and it's amazing how they keep you know
so much fresh ingredients to do it at
least the good ones do uh i' love as a
jersey guy you get mozzarella sticks and
and an omelet you know at any hour of
the day because most of them are open 24
hours and that's uh basically my my
vonka and my go-to will throw in a
milkshake or two as well but for for me
as a kid you know my father would take
me sometimes I'd sit with him in the
meeting sometimes I'd be at the table
next to him he' give me a bunch of
quarters to put in the the music machine
that they would have on the the wall and
it was always just a great experience uh
doing it in Jersey and I joke that you
know if you grow up in Jersey you grow
up with just just enough of a chip on
your shoulder that you have to go and
make something of yourself in life it's
a it's a special place I had an amazing
childhood there and uh very very proud
to be from the state and I I will just
give a little bit of a plug now because
the state has now actually turned the
corner and and they had a$1 billion do
budget surplus for many years um you
know it was a state that was basically
bankrupt and uh and now actually under a
pretty Progressive Democrat Governor
Phil Murphy uh he's turned the state
around and it's actually has a very uh
bright future ahead and it's it's
probably one of the best places uh to
raise a family in the country right it's
got very low crime one of the best
public school systems in the country
pretty good healthare system a lot of uh
green Parks people know the turnpike but
it's got a lot to it uh that's really
great so I'm a big big fan of Jersey you
I like how this is the first for this
particular podcast you literally gave a
plug to a state so New Jersey
everybody it's where it's at it's there
South Jersey there's North Jersey I mean
all there's all kinds of jerseys too I
mean the whole thing it just I and don't
get me started on the Jersey Le that's
thing and I'm not talking about the
snooky part I'm talking about the real
nice Parts where you great food great
people you mean nice Parts it's all
beautiful the full range of human
characters that are in New Jersey are
all beautiful I agree with that and
every time I travel across the world
there's always to meet somebody from New
Jersey and you kind of give a knot of a
deep understanding it's the cradle of
civilization many ways
okay
that